space travel
skydiving emotes save the world going
free-to-play at long last and repping
your favorite fortnight creators sit
back relax use cold and amaru in the
fortnight shop and let's break down
everything we know about season 10
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
did you know I'm gonna hit you with a
face reveal at 1 million subscribers
it's true it's damn true and I'm
terrified so I'll tell your granny to
subscribe before I change my mind anyway
it's time once again to go through
everything fortnight season 10 related
from the predictable to the nonsensical
from the leaked files to the outrageous
insane theories which become more
believable the more you listen so here
are the coolest 10 things I found about
fortnight
season 10 quickly let's keep a tradition
going what will be the silly skin found
in this season's battle pass from
Horrible T foo to a tomato vampire under
banana skin there are some really
strange skins out there but what will
appear in season 10 my prediction is
pickle Ric what do you think okay the
first thing we're going to do is break
down the event there are clues there to
uncover in fact by going even further
back to last season's event we can plot
out the future singularity has already
been in the vault
look her helmet is on the desk it's
actually like a teacher's desk anywhere
remember that because I'll come back to
it later in the present day the Power
Core from the vault rests in the open
slowly cracking but yet again it was
there in the vault hiding in plain sight
from this we can surmise singularity
understands the power of this ball this
Nexus and likely controlled the make
when it fought again to the monster but
now let's go to the fight itself first
note that the monster went straight for
the vault he wasn't messing around
he beeline straight towards it he hang
on a sec why do I say he it's obviously
female it looks like my mother-in-law
she's she he who went straight for the
vault using brute strength to open it
the mech defended the vault with a full
arsenal of rockets but here's the
important part later in the fight the
robot was losing and instead of
protecting the vault it actively opened
it up and utilized the energy inside the
power made them make a worthy winner
that punch was so badass this power then
allowed Robo to lift the sword hidden
within neo tilted and to bring this full
circle it's a statue of singularity who
must have been the pilot so by using the
vault power she could win the fight but
at what cost the vault is now open the
Nexus is here and in season 10 things
are going to
happen the vault has already shown us
parallel universes such as the butterfly
event and last season's on vaulting and
like we've already noticed the
singularity helmet was inside she knew
far more about the vault that she
letters know the power though is too
much for us mere mortals and now
singularity is left we need to
understand the power of the Nexus so
there's the Nexus just chillin away
watching us choose the drum gun probably
disgusted in as all the sphere likely
holds the mythical powers from Kevin the
cube who died for our sins but now we
must trust in spend the sphere no item
stop that you do not name them so I
looked into the Nexus and the only one I
knew was from the WWE when weird but was
at the helm terrible impression my
apologies anyway looking into the
dictionary I looked up Nexus and there
are a few different definitions but the
dictionary tells us that Nexus is
something which connects to unlinking
subjects to things that don't belong
together like battle royale and time
travel alternately in modern day the
word Nexus is used to signify a central
point the thing we all should be paying
attention to interesting isn't it it
makes the time travel theory and
fortnight so much more believable I'm
expecting the Nexus to kind of explode
kinda like in League of Legends
oh no I've said League of Legends you're
going to get League of Legends advert
now I'm so sorry and let me know if you
do I think they're listening to me you
know let's look into time trouble and
the hint we have to this technically
we've seen time travel multiple times in
fortnight remember the rocket event
where it bottled around the map yet
that's time travel when lazy links
tomato temple and the other areas
appeared once again time travel heck
last season the story began going to the
future
and although Jonesy had to wait it out
he already predicted the future hold
that thought we'll come back to those
visions soon other time travel hints
came in the south come on there's a
freaking spaceship here and my personal
favorite look at the shape of the pool
in tilted it's the same shape as a
spaceship the hints are all here the
foreshadowing is real and if we look
into the overtime challenges we can see
hobo Jonesy has a skin variant to make
him look
even older but Stratus has a skin which
makes him look younger somehow so how
can one age but the other become younger
well if we look at the dead monster you
know the one with the sword through its
head and we see how quickly his body
dissolved and how nature claimed back
that space it's far too quickly to be
real-time indicating we are in a place
where time is relative and you know what
I think there's enough evidence here to
say time travel is coming in season 10
but will we go further into the future
or maybe just maybe back in time oh and
if you remember the butterfly event that
came straight from the Doctor Strange
movie in which he time travels
everything comes full circle
last season I talked about two years
after a game releases people long for
the good old days could now be the time
to go back in time back to season zero
or season one I'm not sure about this
but the potential to bring back old
areas of interest is astoundingly easy
to do
moist Amaya could return for a few weeks
maybe greasy Grove rifts back for 10
days how awesome would that be but
here's the issue professional players
players who need consistency to perform
in other words the fortnight World Cup
notice the lack of map changes after the
giant mech and the monster fought I mean
the monster smashed into everything the
simple answer is the World Cup epic
don't want to change the map too much on
the lead-up to a World Cup remember when
the infinity blade was added vo it
ruined everything
the World Cup is the defining moment of
a professional format players Korea but
look when the World Cup ends mm-hmm oh
yes just before the new season drops can
you think of a better time to change the
map massively than after a showpiece
event like the World Cup by changing at
this point the entire cycle can begin
again new map new contestants and in a
year or so another World Cup making each
World Cup completely different from the
last so yeah I expect big changes when
that ball we call the Nexus explodes and
even after one day in the open it
already looks to be coming true the
sphere is cracking
[Music]
right we need to move away from time
travel I've got so much more stuff to
show you but just before we do can I
just take a moment to thank those who
use code a tomorrow in the shop you
helped me out so much and you let me
make original content I really
appreciate that please think about using
my code when you buy next season's
battle puss and in return I'll keep
bringing you as much content as I can
anyway this does feel like begging so
let's move on to something I know is
arriving in season 10 here's something I
said last season
it's loadouts I need these in my life
does this ever happen to you you decide
to change a character but then you also
need to change their backlink their pick
axe their wraps their trails it becomes
a part-time job sometimes with loadouts
we can simply set up a character with
every element perfectly the way we want
it then simply press save your bright
pink character with pink wraps pink
trails pink axe you you get the idea I
like pink I'm a grown man anyway your
character will be saved but whenever you
want to take them into battle again so
yes loadouts we know you're working on
them please put them in this season
[Music]
one of my random predictions last season
was a backward pink cap with a grenade
on it boom check this [ __ ] out did you
buy this again what do you think of it I
think in season 10 this will be the
basis of epics attempt to embrace
youtubers and streamers with links and
partnerships starting with those simple
icons here's a bit of backstory
when saved the world released to sweeten
the deal with youtubers and streamers
epic gave them in-game icons as an
incentive everyone accepts me by the way
I only had 200 subs back then so I can't
expect much really can i well anyway I
comes up to this point have been bloody
useless less than useless clutter I'd
say in the Battle Pass which were
pointless except for the grenade of
course what what but now those icons on
certain character skins can be used to
rep who you want to rep another World
Cup is here expect people to rock their
own logos and get a name out there and
hopefully over season 10 and beyond this
will widen out to all creators you'll be
able to rep whoever you want oh I did
some quick research and it looks like
Ali A's is already here check this out
sorry dude I couldn't resist I love you
really Alistar if the icons project goes
well maybe in season 13 creators will be
able to design their own characters and
epic will put them in the shop one day
your job could be designing characters
in fortnight what a cool job that would
be by the way the precursor to all this
kind of stuff is YouTube loot drops it's
already here have you watched the video
about it if you're watching fortnight
videos on YouTube it'll give you
cosmetics for free to start it up you
need to get your butt over to YouTube
sign in click on settings and connected
accounts epic games will be waiting for
you and they'll give you free stuff for
watching their content is this a good
thing I have no idea we'll find out soon
I suppose
oh oh here's a big one which is slowly
edging closer save the world looks to be
coming free-to-play I know I know what
you're thinking they've said this before
and they fail to deliver and if you
remember of of seasons back I said it
wouldn't go free-to-play because of
those dailyvee buck challenges which
would ruin their ecosystem I mean every
day you can earn 50 bucks and if you log
in every day for a week you earn between
150 and 500 V bucks basically 2000 V
bucks a month for little effort well I
checked the latest patch notes and
notice this in save the world
it reads missions and systems quests
mission alerts and daily login rewards
will now grant x-ray tickets instead of
v bucks to players who are non founders
paid founders will not be affected by
this change
so only founders can grab dailyvee bucks
from now on so let's not sugarcoat this
this is a change preparing to go
free-to-play I'm a founder so I'm cool
with these changes but if you're hoping
to get this game for free and earn 3 V
bucks rip the dream it ain't happening
oh jeez only but at least you know the
PvE game is a little bit closer to
fruition I mean it's a good game I'm not
going to oversell it but there are some
badass characters to meet and you hear
the voices of the BR characters you've
been playing for years
[Music]
oh and there's foreshadowing in the
battle past - it's in the shape of bacon
I want to explain how bacon works and
save the world it's funnier if we just
move on speaking of the battle puss we
usually look at it and find clues for
the following season in the past we've
found the castle that looks at our
outfit and we even predicted the volcano
before it arrived in season 9 battle
paths there are loads of future
references from the movie Blade Runner a
futuristic story about androids
laserdiscs from the movie called Tron
you legit need to watch that it's pretty
damn good but there's no real hint
towards next season unless we're going
further into the future Oh in fact there
is a trowel what the hell could that
mean we're going to do some gardening or
maybe rebuild the island what am I
missing
this trowel is important the holey
trowel a lot of people have noticed that
similarities to apex legend the pink
system the reboot fans and now there's a
monster skeleton just like in apex
legends well one thing which is really
cool about apex last season was the
inclusion of skydiving emotes they are a
huge hit with the community and epic
aren't afraid to steal other people's
content kinda like the fortnight
clickbait community I suppose I really
do like this feature and could
definitely see it make its way over to
fortnight season 10
[Music]
there are other unanswered questions we
need to talk about so you can hopefully
help me find things in future if you
paid attention to the monster during the
fight
he gave us potential clues first he
blasted a circle around Pirates Bay what
could that mean what is he trying to
tell us about the bay
could he be telling us that this is one
of the areas which he's going and also
the arm which he bit off the mech
suggests something could be happening
just below snobby shores the rest of the
mech is in space but the arm the arm is
in the ocean maybe we should check back
in season 15 anyway so there we have it
expect more movie crossovers in season
10 have you also noticed that epic adore
to things late 80s culture like Back to
the Future and Voltron our Power Rangers
at you're younger and they also love
Keanu Reeves I mean who doesn't he's
breathtaking so here's my complete
unrelated prediction for the seasons
ahead have you ever seen Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure in turn eighties
film starring Keanu Reeves as he travels
around time to save the future how
perfect would that fit in with fortnight
season 10 you can have it for free epic
games just give me more Keanu please
that's all I need oh and if by magic the
next Bill and Ted movie is on its way
coincidence I think not right that's
enough I'm sure you're sick of my
annoying voice in your ear holes please
think about using code a Demario and I
promise to continue covering fortnight
every single week in season 10 using my
code works on the battle pass too by the
way anyway much love thank you very much
for watching and if you stayed this long
right grenade in the comments I will try
and find you and give you some love
anyway I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time